deuxième réussite personnalisée elle
aussi à l'étranger hanae mori cette fois
ci il s'agit d'une femme est ici c'est
extrêmement rare c'est la seule femme de
la haute couture japonaise à paris et
c'est d'ailleurs en france qu'elle est
venue chercher plus que la consécration
le label qui lui permet de vendre ici
est de bien vendre ses robes s'appelle
maintenant hanae mori paris elle a
pignon sur rue sur les deux artères les
plus chics ici l'endroit où tout le
monde se montre à tokyo et puis à paris
avenue montaigne
c'est d'ailleurs là que patricia jean
nolet a commencé son reportage
la haute couture japonaise se crée et se
fabrique à paris cette jeune femme
effectue un stage dans un atelier de
l'avenue montaigne
car c'est ici qu'est né le numéro un
japonais de la haute couture hanae mori
du nombre de sa créatrice un chiffre
d'affaires de près de 2 milliards de
francs
il ya près de 30 ans qu'anna et maury a
fondé son premier studio de création
mais ce n'est qu'en 1977 qu'elle
s'installe en france avec l'aide d'henri
bergot m
en fait je crois qu'il n'y a pas de
consécration pour un couturier sans être
admis par paris c'est à dire être
reconnu par ses pairs et avoir sa maison
de création son studio son équipe à
paris je crois que ça c'est
indispensable pour la notoriété
internationale
et vous
hanae mori à tokyo ambassadrice de la
mode française comme elle l'est à paris
de la création japonaise
issu d'une famille traditionnelle elle a
porté le kimono jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans
elle ignorait donc tout de la mode mais
déjà elle voulait être artiste des sla
contre la volonté de son père après des
études de littérature elle se marie et
elle apprend très vite le stylisme elle
deviendra alors la première utilise
japonaise au japon son succès
d'exceptionnel d'abord parce qu'elle est
une femme
elle explique elle même que dans son
pays les rues difficile pour une femme
que pour un homme de rien enfin
difficile également d'acquérir des mots
ses autres responsabilités un quart des
femmes et elles ne sont pas au départ
considéré comme légal désarme pas fini
les raisons de son succès sont lisibles
fallait d'abord le talent ensuite la
santé et puis surtout le travail depuis
l'ouverture de sa maison de haute
couture à paris il ya cinq ans hanae
mori dit elle même qu'elle n'a jamais
pris de vacances
l'exemple est donc donné aujourd'hui
pour toute une nouvelle génération de
créateurs japonais qui viennent chercher
à paris le label haute qualité